[Music]
joe
are you interested in purchasing uh
real estate yeah i was gonna get a
duplex
or a triplex why what's up how about for
yourself
maybe one day but i see it as not really
my thing
not really anything i'm gonna buy new
mexico in new mexico
the state you're buying new mexico oh
i might partner up and get a farm in
california
nice well uh there was this homeowner
so he purchased this this one particular
home
for about twenty thousand dollars in
texas
wow it was supposed to be a fixer-upper
kind of house because it was previously
owned by a hoarder
that's a car price it could be like one
of those trailer homes
yeah now that you see that 20 000.
that's cheap even for texas holy
remember i saw
that um studio apartment for sale in
honolulu for 30 000.
yeah it was a 400 square foot apartment
for 30 000
in hawaii that's really good yeah well
this place
it's it is a three-bedroom property
and he purchased this two years ago and
it had remained empty for a year
following the death of the previous
owner who
like i said was a hoarder so it wasn't
empty
he's full of [ __ ] yeah apparently
and then so he had this home right
and then about two months or three
months after he made the purchase
probably got a lot of treasure uh there
was this really
really really heavy rainfall that
that happened right and then after that
rainfall
his neighbor called him and was like hey
so like how's your house is everything
okay like how's your pool
he was like what what pool i don't have
a pool
oh the neighbor was like yeah you do
yeah you do
you have a pool oh he got a new pool and
then so
so then he goes to the backyard and he's
covered in grass and [ __ ] that
his that there was a hidden pool under
under all this oh [ __ ]
so for 20 000 he got a house with a pool
yes
well why does that pool oh the house
looks so good for 20 grand that's a 20
grand house dude
he probably walked on it this is what it
looked like before what
it was just covered with like piles of
stuff even like
like items and stuff but that just looks
like grass right yeah there's a pool
underneath
the scariest thing falling into it whoa
oh i see it oh so
like the edge right you can make out
make out the edge none of that was
hold on wait so he bought this property
and nobody told him what
i know you don't get the blueprints or
anything well they probably didn't mean
though so look look check it out
wow i want a skateboard in there it's a
40 000
gallon pool that's a big property too
20 000. that's beautiful so now he has
spent it took him 11
months to clear everything out and like
revamp and
all this stuff so originally he was he
was
um intending for this home to just be
like for him to flip the house and then
get a profit somehow
but now he says that throughout this
whole time of renovating
renovating this home he fell in love he
has he says that this home just has so
many other surprises which i don't know
about
he finds more things there's a sauna
did this happen porter's homes a hoarder
home you never know what you're going to
find in there
you find like an underground lair then
it's like a parking lot full of golden
cars
my dad's kind of a hoarder so like we
would have like warehouses filled with
like just random stuff or from like his
old
bees we had like a furniture at rec
store mad carpets and stuff
but like actual like electronics and
stuff so like just going and exploring
you would have the funnest time climbing
up boxes finding rap like i found
boxes full of swords i found like old
does he still have all that stuff uh we
took the good stuff and left the rest so
he's kee so he's keeping the house
twenty thousand dollars
eleven months to clean this thing yeah
so he ended up feeling oh no
actually eighteen months sorry eighteen
months
to clear out and renovate so he was
living somewhere else
during this whole process probably well
if he's gonna flip it he's probably not
even living this yeah yeah exactly so
he ended up deciding exactly to keep the
house
and guess how much it's worth now uh 700
120 000. 200 300.
wait wait wait texas where is texas
we're thinking california
three million dollars mineral wells
hundred and forty five to two hundred
thousand dallas
a little bit it's near fort worth oh so
near
dallas area 200 000 then hundred
thousand
three hundred you didn't read this one i
go i reached two hundred
thousand and one oh three hundred
thousand three hundred
i'm 150 to two hundred four hundred okay
150 to 200.
it's so funny because that will get you
nothing in l.a god the price is right
this is fun i know right minimum is like
seven
yeah don't even talk about let's not
talk about up north oh san francisco is
nuts
i could never afford to live there okay
i'm too poor for it i live on the street
so now his home is worth
223.
yes the only reason why i did that
because she said did you read it i said
oh that's the answer
oh yeah i didn't even think about that
yeah
damn two hundred two hundred oh he came
up so good awful twenty
he came up two hundred thousand well who
knows how much he spent on renovation
and then
but it's it took him 18 months to make
two hundred thousand because he was
moving slow
no but i think he did it on his own with
with like some friends or something very
little money so i
assume that he did not spend a lot on i
read how much he spent he only spent
seven thousand nine hundred dollars
to renovate the whole thing stop it
really where something like that and i
don't read that so 27 000
total for this place there's something
called like the the burr method that's
beautiful
it's like buy renovate resell or
something uh but they say like you buy
it's 10 thousand it was seven thousand
british pounds
oh is it a british article that's still
nothing you buy it say 400
renovate for a hundred thousand sell for
like seven hundred thousand you make two
hundred i pay like twenty four hundred
dollars a month
for my pla i know i pay like that or a
little more for a [ __ ] room
a room i save four grand a month now
i know you got a great look at the
original one thousand two hundred
stop it including utilities and wi-fi
and everything oh god
and he has a pool a saltwater pool i saw
a water that's not even mine
and he gets to rent a family what the
hell do you get to borrow kids
yes and give him over whenever there's a
dog
and he delivers food stop it if you're
looking to adopt me
yep you need a grown-ass woman living in
your backyard
you know what stop i actually i can't
sell myself because somebody will
probably offer that's that's true
in my case it was my friend yeah my
friends
will be your friend when i'm on vacation
you can go okay yeah
when i come when i come and stay in how
big is your space it's
like the size of this place right here
yeah it's like the size of it it's a
little bigger
it's like okay well we did talk about
moving in together
yeah we did talk about moving in
together but we need a really big place
right because we both like personal
space yeah we really like we just need
the kitchen as the common area i mean we
could just get like a duplicate no no we
need like we need like
four bedrooms four bedrooms four because
i need an office space right me too
separate there's no way we're sharing
enough you need a duplex that's the
truth right we need a duplex
so let's so we're like roommates but
like with two houses right
old place our old place was a duplex so
it was like one gigantic house
split down the middle and it was two
bedrooms two bedrooms
and then one bathroom and then one
kitchen on each side so that's the house
you need
but we need the salt water pool i don't
think you can give that i kind of want
to rent a family that's like the whole
thing
it'll be kind of lonely if it's just us
too we just like
expand on their property oh that sounds
pretty cool can i
build on it like can i have a similar
space like yours he's pretty nice you'll
have some nice properties
and skid row see unfortunately
um i'm looking to rank his family does
it come with the family it comes with
like thousands of people
family you can consider anyone could
become family
she wants to
this is how sick it is right last night
um he's like you want some tacos i'm
trying to get the kids to go to sleep
because he was like driving him in the
car
so he comes back he has nachos tacos
whatever i come to
eat and as i'm eating i feel something
by my feet
and there's a little boy just holding
onto my leg and staring up at me like
this
and then over here there's a jealous
bigger sister that's staring up
up and then both of them are just
staring at me while i'm eating tacos and
just drop some like taco meat on the
floor
no i just picked them up i dropped the
taco and i picked them up
but uh see you get the the perks of
living
at uh rena family house yeah i want to
live there and i have a family i know
right
i feel like i love my spot way better
than
what i had before there's so much space
but it's it just feels weird their pool
is nice too
super nice i have a jacuzzi too oh yeah
it's nice i walk up three steps and it's
a heated saltwater water people are just
two steps away from the video
damn you said you felt like you're on
vacation when you're there i
i do and i'm on vacation a lot so
my house it takes like hours to heat up
our jacuzzi oh
my god my pool was closed down for
months and i paid for it still i'm so
pissed off i live in an apartment i live
in a bar you should get some money back
for that
first off we gonna fight they lucky that
i don't know where they live yet
because they don't the people that own
the complex are not there it would be so
much funnier if they actually live there
they don't live there you know how many
times we like
and you don't really want to start like
i don't really want to start [ __ ]
but i'd be like you talk to the neighbor
everyone so i'll be like
so did they say anything about the pool
yet she's like no did you write them i'm
like
i don't know if i can carry that like i
don't i don't know yet
i don't know yet yeah and she's like a
couple of the other people's
been writing emails i think it's okay
there's like a secret like hidden
message way like where
because they have an app so you can pay
everything on an app now
just start a facebook group i don't
facebook
and our neighborhood has a facebook then
you gotta dm everyone and start a group
on the uh
but i don't need them knowing i see now
this is where it gets complicated
because i don't need them knowing i live
there
do you notice cause they'll be like
you're famous oh not even i
the one of the ladies that worked in the
office found me on instagram
and she commented on a video with me and
my dog and she was like i didn't know
you lived here and i just was like see
this
is why when i talk to the original
people and
yeah so when they have new people
circulating for the jobs it's like all
is why i love my maintenance team
they're super
nice and really quiet but i was like i
don't want to write and start [ __ ]
and i'm not going to rally the troops to
go protest on opening up a damn pool
because we're paying for it so i'm like
can you i i'll co-sign it if you do it
i'm not trying to start [ __ ] people
don't even know i'm like recording the
shows that they're listening to right
next door to them
i mean like they have no idea they're
like what do you do for a living
you should be like hey like it was so
weird i saw some guy running with like a
knife along the walls like cutting the
walls
and he said he was not edward scissors
hand yeah just like leaving marks until
they opened the pool back up
it wasn't me though i thought my
imagination is
not that good or just like hey
someone like flooded the floors being
like i'm gonna swim here if we cancel in
the pool
we pay a lot for these apartments
they're like listen you can move out
we'll move somebody else in
yeah yeah they're they're at that
they're at that point to where they're
like listen we don't care about you
[Music]
you